Categorical data represents characteristics, such as a
player's position, team, hometown or even, handedness. Categorical
data can take on numerical values. For example,
maybe we'd use 1 for first baseman and
2 for second baseman. But these numbers
don't have a mathematical meaning. That is, we
can't add them together or take the average.
There's also something called ordinal data, which in
some sense is a mix of numerical and
categorical data. In ordinal data, the data still falls
into categories, but those categories have some order or
ranking. For example, a scout might rank a baseball
player's power on a scale from very low to
very high. Another example is that you might give
a movie anywhere between 1 star and 5 stars
and these might be ordinal categories. For plotting purposes,
ordinal data is treated much in the same way as categorical data. But the
groups are usually ordered from lowest to
highest, so that we can preserve this ordering.